ستسمعون عن الكمبيوتر الكمي كثيرا في
الاشهر المقبله وهو جهاز خارق اقرب ما
يكون لعصا سحريه تضع حلولا مثاليه في
اوقات قياسيه لمشاكل معقده مثل التغيرات
المناخيه وتفشي الاوبئه والازمات
الاقتصاديه ومشكلات اخرى تتطلب معالجتها
الكثير من الحظ احيانا وقرونا من الزمن
شركات التكنولوجيا مثل مايكروسوفت
تعمل على تطوير كمبيوتر كمي ليحل محل
الكمبيوتر التقليدي الذي يعد محدود
القدرات نظرا لاستخدامه نظام تشفير يعتمد
على الاحاد او الاسفار بينما يعمل
الكمبيوتر الكمي وفق نظام مركب يوظف
الاحاد والاصفار او كليهما معا في ان واحد
ما يمكنه من انجاز حسابات هائله بسرعه
كبيره
عدد لا يحصى من الحلول والاكتشافات يمكن
ان يحققها الكمبيوتر الكمي في المجالات
كافه سواء لتسريع اكتشاف الادويه عن طريق
محاكاه سلوك الجزيئات او الحد من الهدر في
الطاقه الكهربائي اثناء ايصالها او تقليل
تكاليف الانتاج او تطوير نماذج ماليه
دقيقه تسمح بالتنبؤ باتجاهات السوق
[موسيقى]
خوارزميات الكمبيوتر الكمي تتطلب فهما
عميقا لميكانيكي الكم لكن المعضله ان هذا
المجال العلمي لا يزال فتيا ومؤخرا فقط
بدات بعض الجامعات الامريكيه ومن بينها
جامعات وسكانسون
تقديم دورات وتخصصات في دراسه فيزياء الكم
وظواهرها
تعاني الولايات المتحده من نقص كبير في
المواهب في هذا المجال ومع ذلك يعد
التمويل الحكومي لدراسه فيزياء الكم ضئيلا
جدا مقارنه بالصين واوروبا لصباح العربيه
هند ابراهيم واشنطن